- I make mistakes every day.
Life's about alternatives.
If you don't
believe in me as a leader,
go work somewhere else.
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
What's up, everybody?
Thursday morning,
pretty, pretty solid day ahead.
Got a bunch of
internal meetings,
a bunch of
interviews and then
I've got the keynote.
Today's the first
day we're doing the 4Ds,
the Daily Digital Deep Dive,
that some of you are aware of,
which is kind of a
Zappos, Disney-like product,
we've created at VaynerMedia,
where they go
through a 10 hour day,
12 people, 13 people
and really get
to know each other,
really get to know
all the disciplines,
that make modern marketing work.
So, I'm excited about that,
and the first five or 10 tours
I'm gonna do the keynote,
so I'm excited for that.
I'll go do that today
and then get to see David Levy,
president of Turner later,
client, friend, genius
and then a big team dinner
with a small group of
VaynerMedia employees.
I'm just putting
together different groups
and jamming with peeps,
so staying in the trenches,
CEO life, baby, CEO life.
(gentle guitar music)
(gentle upbeat music)
Yo, what up Instagram?
Just got out of a
meeting with a Fortune 50 CFO,
talked some real biz,
was a Jets fan,
so we talked a
little bit about that.
Now heading back,
got some more meetings.
Pretty aggressive
day, big day today.
First day of the 4Ds.
Daily Digital Deep Dive.
It's where
people come to Vayner,
spend the day consulting,
getting to learn,
so things are good.
What up, what up, what up.
I have now come
to the realization,
that everybody's
gonna have an opinion on me.
When it's all said and done,
- [Vinita] Yeah.
- which is cool,
and I'm excited about
and I just want the
people that are closest to me
to have the best opinion,
'cause they know the truth.
(gentle music)
Good day so far?
- [Steve] These guys
have been amazing.
It's been so--
- I know these guys, these guys,
I'm sure have been amazing.
How have you been, Steve?
(group laughter)
To me that's the question.
I think the thing,
that you need to understand
and this becomes very
rewarding, which is
you're young enough that
you do it for two years
and if it doesn't
work out, Shoots.
I forced Shoots
into this situation
of ultimately
gonna be running this.
I could be right, I could
be wrong, I'm intuitive.
I take on that
responsibility as a leader.
I also knew that means he
could of came back a day later
and been like,
"I don't wanna do that.
"Can you help me
get a different job?"
and he could,
because he knows me,
he knows that
that would be the case.
I think I'm right.
We can find out.
He knows, the company knows,
I killed project management.
I brought it back, like, ah!
- [Shoots] Yeah.
- Like, we spend so
much time overthinking,
instead of doing.
Do it, then know, then decide.
Yeah, I think it is
cool and you know what it is?
It's liberating, which
then allows you to go fast.
- Speed, yeah.
- Speed, it's all speed.
Like, you gotta go fast.
That's how you get shit done,
that's how you figure stuff out
and then like, if you're
wrong, you say you're wrong.
(gentle guitar music)
Thanks guys, have a great day.
Yeah, awesome.
(group applause)
Before you guys
leave, I'll try to come in
and maybe I'll do,
I'm sure some--
- [Man] Selfie.
- selfie or whatever,
yeah, I'll come back.
Awesome
- Sweet.
- Omar Gare,
I have a gift for you.
- [Gary] Yes, yes, yes.
- Now, you said, Fila--
- [Gary] Yes, yes.
- would be the one
you'd bring back, right?
- Yes, yes, I love it.
- [Omar] Had to give you,--
- Thank you, man.
- [Omar] the 96, Grant Hills.
- I love this Grant Hills.
Dude, I love it,
I'm gonna rock it.
- Yeah, 10 and a half, so--
- [Gary] My man, thank you,--
- appreciate it.
- very nice, thank you.
- Makes it harder, huh?
- I know how to do this.
(laughing)
- I opened this kind
of boxes my whole life.
Alright, I'm excited, excited.
- Woah!
- [Gary] Uh-huh.
Helmet, Ty?
'80, '69 Jets?
- Of course.
- I love it, man,
thank you so much.
- All signed up for the box.
- Unbelievable.
- With just a simple
note for just like...
Like a thank you for
all the amazing stuff
you do for the world.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] I appreciate it.
- Thank you so much.
- [Gary] It's very nice.
I'll see you
guys in a little bit.
Alright, Ty, what's up?
Where we going?
(gentle music)
- What's that?
So, I think I can really help.
That's why I wanna have that
conversation with you guys,
and so we'll have that.
- [Man 2] Cool.
- Cool, awesome brother.
- Appreciate it.
- Great to see you again.
Marcus, when are
you off crutches?
- I'm getting
re-evaluated on Wednesday.
I'll probably be
on like one, and then--
- [Gary] One? (laughing)
- Well, 'cause
you basically like,
you kind of have to like, hobble
it's almost like a cane
and then, and then
it's just like a transition.
- I'm so happy he
has to do that part.
(gentle music)
I love it.
Thanks guys, take
care, my pleasure.
- [Woman] Take care,
looking forward to seeing you.
- Me too, bye bye.
(gentle guitar music)
- Good
- Nice to meet you.
- Such a pleasure.
Good to officially meet.
- Officially, I know.
- Anything I can answer for you?
- [Casey] No, I don't think so.
- Okay.
- [Casey] I just
wanted to kind of like,--
- Make it official.
- [Casey] say, "Hi!"
Make it official.
- My inbox is open
to you, anything, like,
I really mean it.
(gentle, upbeat music)
- My question for
you is really, like,
what is a well-rounded
digital marketer?
- It's somebody who,
I think the best digital--
- You know that I mean?
- Of course I do.
- Yeah.
- It's the one that
understands, that he or she
needs to have the short-term
skills of the moment--
- Right.
- and the intuition
and tasting ability,
when I say tasting,
the intuitive curiosity
around things like
influencer marketing,
and then as soon
as you buy into it,
become a practitioner in that.
- Right.
- Like, it's always doing that.
It's always
knowing that the thing,
that we care about the most
is already on
its way of being out,
and to look at the
counter and collateral damage
of its execution.
(upbeat music)